[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir il me semble que nicolas et
pimprenelle font beaucoup de bruit ce
soir j'ai bien l'impression qu'ils sont
en train de se disputer
je descends voir son patron j'ai peur
qu'ils le fassent des bêtises
mon seul homme propos prend pas pour des
habits
alors que se passe-t-il vous en faites
du bruit ou lol quel désordre
c'est cette fille enfin non c'est toi
nicolas c'est par principe et maman a
dit qu'il faudra gérer l'eau à l'eau du
calme si vous arrêtez de vous disputer
je vais vous était d'accord
ce que tu nous as l'air disque plus bon
3 du color du range d'orly il y en a
dans tous les coins toi pas preneur du
balai
mais moi nounours je vais mettre de
l'ordre dans la cus et wind à nous mais
tu nous jette une chanson pour nous
encourager
we all aux autres vols
[Musique]
je me souviens
quoi
enjeu de petit jeu
sous vivant
de bain petite maman chérie
10 heures
on va faire les courses
il ya plus de là
on a poussé on nous moi je répondais j'y
cours maman joli haut et vite chaleur
jusqu'à la berge bruit quand j'étudiais
marc rémillard
le demandeur
tu tu abuses hier avec moi je répondeur
jeu
droit de masse truire au camp
bush vous le
savoir lire écrire
ma soeur emilie a joué à la barre ou
en sont hors jeu la dre la vue initiale
aux dons
je n'oublie pas
que ma maman tout
jour et des venir de moi
pas
oui vraiment bien se conduire au sel
faire plaisir à sa chute
magro
tu vois là tout tombe de haut
mais tu sais c'est drôle de ranger la
maison c'est très amusant et du même si
tu veux aux acteurs méthodes et yao
n'ont eu d'autres fois on apprenait on
va s'coucher which in rome en une nuit
ce qu'ils peuvent te 38 quand ils le
veulent
vous voyez comme c'est facile de mettre
de l'ordre de ranger ses affaires et
d'aider sa maman moi je le dis toujours
ma maman patron je te un fils exemple
heures je le sais mon gros nounours
allons en route
bonne nuit les petits embrasser bien
fort vos parents le feu de beauvais
[Musique]